now during today's covet zoom call the
task force shared some new information
about tracking copic cases in our
schools so the task force also talked
about how counties across our state are
dealing with different hospitalization
trends that are associated with the
virus and kirsten joyce joining us in
studio with details you were listening
in on that discussion today yes denise
and brian today the department of health
and human services rolled out an update
to the state's covet 19 school dashboard
with information on cases in schools
across our state they can be searched by
county or school and provide data on
cases for staff and students who are
present at school while infected with
coven 19 and this is updated weekly the
task force also shared that counties
across our state are experiencing
divergent trends with cases of copin 19.
the number of cases number of people
hospitalized as well for coven 19 both
falling in southern and northern nevada
but dr ellie grayden says
hospitalizations continue to rise by 15
in rural parts of our state
given the primary strain of the virus
circulating last spring we had been
targeting the goal of 70
for vaccination rates
but with this more contagious virus we
now know that that goal needs to be
higher
but dr ellie grayden does not know yet
by how much
on average 64 of eligible nevadans have
been partially vaccinated but she says
that's below the national average of 75
percent and as for boosters if you are
eligible to receive them at this point
we're told there is an ample supply
across our state brian